it's my pleasure to introduce you next
to Samuel Gregg now I see a few friendly
faces out there who've been to act in
University so you know this guy but for
some of you who don't know I'll tell you
a little bit about him Sam is a
colleague of mine at Acton I had the
great fortune of successfully recruiting
him I think in 2000 from Australia to be
the director of research at Acton and
his job then and continues to be to
write and speak on questions of
political economy economic history
ethics and Finance and natural law
theory he has a doctorate in moral
philosophy and political economy from
from Oxford he's the author of at least
eleven books I say at least because he
dropped in some in a email last week
that he had some book sitting at a
publisher I don't think it's listed on
here and I saw him scribble scribble
scribble encoder there so I suspect he's
finished another one this morning but
some of his books include morality law
and public policy on ordered liberty and
the prize-winning the commercial society
he publishes and constantly and national
and international journals and he cited
frequently in global news organizations
including the arc Times Wall Street
Journal
Forbes Weekly Standard etc etc it's a
great pleasure to welcome Sam and
introduce my colleague dr. Samuel great
thank you Chris
ladies and gentlemen it's very good to
be with you this morning at Hillsdale
College's free market forum I've heard
so much about this event I've I know
many of you with me many familiar faces
here it's good to see you all again the
theme that I've been asked to talk about
this morning actually flows very well
from some of the things that Dave
Darrell just talked about but also I
think some it's one of these themes that
my colleagues and I at the Acton
Institute spend a lot of time thinking
about and that's the relationship
between free markets on the one hand and
what is often called the common good on
the other now I think it's fair to say
that the relationship between free
markets and the common good is very much
a subject for debate these days and not
just on the political left it's also a
debate that's a live debate now on the
political right among people who call
themselves for example conservatives
there are lots of people who freely
acknowledge that market economies have
radically reduced radically reduced
poverty at a faster rate than any other
economic system in history but they say
life and human wellbeing as a whole
can't be reduced to economic well-being
and when it is you're essentially buying
into materialism which is true that's
not a reason to reject free markets nor
is there a shortage of people who see
the habits and institutions of free
markets on the one hand and the
requirements of what's called the common
good on the other as largely being at
odds various forms of political economy
ranging from more or less Keynesian
economic arrangements to corporatism to
European social democracy to democratic
socialism etc are widely seen as more
compatible with the demands of what's
often called the
good now what I find curious and
revealing about all this is that phrases
like the market or the common good are
often used in these discussions without
too much clarity about definition what
do we mean by free markets what do we
mean by the common good now I think
clarity about those definitions matters
because it provides us with ways of
showing with intellectual precision how
free markets can and often do serve the
common good and that's what I want to do
this morning I want to provide some
definition in order to illustrate how
the free market promotes what I'll call
all-round
integral human flourishing the
flourishing of individuals and
communities because that is the goal of
the common good now when people use the
phrase of the common good it's often
used without too much attention to the
lineage of this particular expression in
many cases it's a type of synonym it's a
substitute for words like community or
society or common ownership but I
suspect that with least this audience
there's a lot of awareness that the
common good is none of these things the
common good is a phrase with deep roots
in the aristotelian to Mystic and
Christian intellectual traditions and
when you look at these traditions you
find very quickly that the common good
doesn't mean society it doesn't mean
community
it doesn't mean collective and it
certainly doesn't mean socialism or
communism
on one level the common good is the good
of all and the good of all is all-round
human flourishing and the content of
human flourishing concerns those goods
those moral goods that lie at the heart
of what it means to be human
common goods like work like beauty like
friendship like religion in the sense of
seeking and trying to know the truth
about the transcendent even the good of
using human reason itself when we choose
those Goods in a potentially infinite
number of ways we become more fully
human more fully who we are supposed to
be but there's another way in which
these traditions use the phrase the
common good and that's to describe those
conditions the conditions which make it
easier for us to freely choose these
Goods think of it this way it's not
impossible for people to choose goods
like work or beauty or knowledge in
conditions of communism or Anarchy but
it's hard it's also much easier to make
free choices for these Goods when rule
of law prevails when there's less
arbitrary power when there's more
reliability about the supply of goods
and services when there's economic
growth and when there is declining
economic poverty so the common good
amount to the sum total of all these
conditions that help people to realize
human flourishing under their own
volition
now I stress those three words under 4
words under your own volition these
words matter because you can't make
people flourish you can't make people
freely choose
anything because no matter how difficult
or conducive the conditions might be for
human flourishing human flourishing is
not going to occur unless people make
free choices these Goods that I'm
referring to now the need for people to
make these free choices doesn't imply a
type of government free society in fact
there are some factors some conditions
of the common good like rule of law
National Defense foreign policy etc that
necessitate a type of authority that has
unique responsibilities for upholding
these conditions we call that authority
the state or the government but sorting
out the government's responsibilities
regarding the common good is not a
simple affair because if governments are
constantly pre-empting or trying to
predetermine our free choices then our
scope for free choice will start to
become very circumscribed and very
limited on the other hand the absence of
certain institutional factors that rely
heavily upon state authority like the
rule of law can if we don't have those
things they can drastically limit our
ability to flourish the situation is
even more complicated when we realize
that some of the conditions associated
with the common good are essential for
human flourishing and don't change and
others are much more relative the rule
of law for example is a permanent
condition of the common good
everyone's opportunities for flourishing
are dramatically undermined if we don't
have rule of law but other conditions of
the rule of law are much more subject
circumstances we allow for a gut for
example governments to do things in
wartime that we would never let them do
in conditions of peace it's also the
case that the vast majority of the
conditions that make up the common good
are not especially
well realized by the state the raising
of children
is a good example this is best
accomplished by intact families and
sometimes not so intact families state
institutions by contrast are not
especially well known for their
successes in rearing children we also
know that when the government tries to
usurp the role of other institutions and
communities in establishing various
conditions associated with the common
good the state can actively contribute
to human denigration maybe the best
example of that is the collectivization
of economic life the historical evidence
of the severe damage to the common good
is ample from the experience of real
socialism and communist economies in the
20th century but also I have to say in
more recent times the economic and
political catastrophe
otherwise known as Venezuela so I think
at this point we can begin to ask
ourselves how does the free market serve
the common good or more precisely how
does the come how does free market
helped to establish conditions that
allow people to flourish under their own
volition but before we think about that
let's be clear about what we mean by the
free market by free market I don't mean
business or Commerce or trade per se you
all know better than most the business
commerce and trade can exist and even
grow in conditions that are not those of
a free market no less than Adam Smith
who I don't know about you but I find
myself returning to read him more and
more and more these days he made the
point and not just in his Wealth of
Nations that business and commerce can
do very well for themselves for
themselves in economic conditions that
are far removed
from a free market one reason for Adam
Smith's barely disguised animus against
merchants he really didn't like
businesspeople very much was his insight
that many business people generally
didn't like competition instead he said
businesses tended to prefer the type of
political favors which are central to
the what he called the mercantile system
that's the target of part four of his
Wealth of Nations
I don't think it's too much to say that
we today live in a world in which
mercantilist economic arrangements are
far more pervasive than we often realize
so what's a market economy if it's not
simply an economy in which private
enterprises the norm rather than state
enterprise I think we get closer to the
meaning of a market economy when we
think of it as first of all one networks
of economic creativity economic exchange
an economic consumption that are for the
most part free to the embedding of those
networks in a particular institutional
framework characterized by private
property arrangements and rule of law
and three a particular set of attitudes
and dispositions that are very difficult
to find in other forms of economic
arrangements those three features I'd
suggest are what mark off the market
economy from say mixed economies and
certainly from collectivized economies
and taken together I think they help to
realize key conditions of the common
good without which human flourishing is
so much more difficult so you might ask
well how does this occur
what are the conditions that markets
help to realize well there's a lot and
we don't have time to do them all today
so let me suggest five such conditions
five conditions which I think are
especially important in the first place
number one I think markets reflect
certain truths about human beings about
human nature that we ignore at our peril
if we really care about the common good
after all
real existing socialism imploded partly
because it denied it denied certain
truths about human beings such as the
fact that we possess among all creatures
the unique capacity to make free choices
or that none of us can look ahead and
foresee all the possible needs of an
entire society at any one point in time
in the near or distant future so in that
sense the market economy is very much
characterized by an understanding of
human beings that's marked by realism
realism about who we are many of the
market economies legal and economic
structures are predicated on a decidedly
non out turistic understanding of humans
contracts exist in part because there
will always be some people who
unreasonably decide to not fulfill their
promises so my point is this market
economies don't make the mistake of
trying to eliminate human fallibility
those who first wrote about the rise of
commercial society who made arguments
for markets over mecan't ilysm noted the
markets ability to align human
self-regard
with a society's overall progress
towards a more materially prosper
set of conditions Adam Smith's reference
to the invisible hand is often a source
of perplexity for some people but I like
to characterize it as simply a metaphor
for the idea that through allowing
people to pursue their self-interest
unintended but beneficial social
consequences follow as individuals
pursue profit for example they
unintentionally add to the sum total of
wealth and society they unintentionally
allow others to benefit from jobs that
would not have been created in the first
place etc now I'm sure we don't need to
remind this audience that the pursuit of
self-interest by individuals and groups
alike remains perhaps the most
controversial feature of free markets
when twentieth-century economic
historians like RH Toni when they
portrayed the age of Commerce as the age
of acquisitiveness they associated the
pursuit of self-interest with the
indulgence of greed and a type of
ruthlessness
but these observations rarely account
for the fact that the self in
self-interest is capable of being other
regarding and even critical of his or
her own behavior nor do they acknowledge
that every self is enveloped in a web of
relationships ranging from the
contractual to the familial all of which
moderate and help to direct our economic
self-interest it's even possible to
speak of a reasonable self love when
figures like Aristotle and Aquinas and
other thinkers of the classical moral
tradition underline the imperative of
people pursuing virtue they did so
because they regarded this as a natural
result of people engaging in a
reasonable form of self regard
tocqueville's observations of American
commercial society in the 18th
30s echo some very similar themes in
democracy in America
Tocqueville presented his readers with
the paradox that self-interest properly
understood was the primary means by
which Americans combated radical
individualism in this new post
aristocratic world of America top Vil
was adamant that all people whether they
were rich or poor believed that quote by
serving his fellow man one serves
oneself and people believe that doing
good is to their private advantage
self-interest properly understood
Tocqueville stressed set people against
what might be called their narrow
self-interest and their selfishness in
other words we start to see here the
wisdom of tocqueville's remarked that
while self-interest properly understood
might not be a sublime doctrine its
workings in market orders can have more
than material benefits now I think this
pursuit of right self-interest rightly
understood is pre conditioned upon our
ability to discern what this
self-interest in particular
circumstances might be and then to act
freely so to that extent I think markets
help to promote a second condition of
the common good and that's a high
commitment to Liberty now too many
people that seems self-evident but it
hasn't always been the case in notes
written during his travels in England
and Ireland for example Tocqueville felt
compelled to highlight this ultimate
dependence of commercial society and
trade and markets upon Liberty now the
essence I think I've talked meal's
argument is that particular moral
qualities that are essential for freedom
are also very conducive
for success in the marketplace
Tocqueville goes on to describe how what
he calls the spirit of Commerce flows
from those who rely upon themselves and
who look restlessly at the present and
imagine how it can be transformed for
the better
all of which requires freedom to do so
so while markets can contribute to the
spread of freedom it's also true that
there's no possibility of widespread
markets without Liberty if there isn't
for example a considerable degree of
freedom concerning people what people
buy and sell then trade and free
exchange
become impossible for consumers and
sellers
likewise unless people are free to
associate with who they choose there's
no possibility of commercial legal
mediums like contracts competition also
relies upon Liberty the liberty of
people to offer a similar good or
product at lower prices than other
organizations and individuals the very
essence of economic entrepreneurship is
a high degree of freedom of personal
initiative now some of these freedoms
certainly existed in premarket pre
commercial societies but they tended to
be strictly limited in their application
or they were largely denied to large
categories of people not just serfs
for example but also members of the
nobility in many countries who risked
losing their noble status if they
engaged in commercial activity
now there's one point that I think we
should state whenever we talk about the
capacity of markets to magnify freedom
more generally throughout society and
it's this we can now look at a number of
countries and say that there's nothing
inevitable about this process opening a
country like China
two markets an opening which I think we
should probably now concede turns out to
have been far more limited and far more
selective and I think many of us
realized isn't a guarantee that Liberty
is going to seep over into other areas
of life that certainly has not happened
in China and it illustrates that
increases in economic Liberty doesn't
don't necessarily lead to increases of
freedom in realms like politics and
religion again China is showing that
right now if anything Liberty has
experienced significant patel months in
some of these areas in recent years in
countries like China now that said what
we can say is that markets do create
some space and some freedom in ways that
a collectivized economy cannot and are
incapable of doing and that's better
than no freedom at all if only because
authoritarian regimes if they're smart
enough know that they can only do go so
far if they don't want to stifle
economic growth and productivity
now this attention to freedom brings me
to the third condition of the common
good that I think's especially important
for human flourishing in which markets
are very good at helping us to realize
and this concerns the freedom to be
creative human beings are unique in the
sense that we are the only species
capable of creativity we seem to be
designed in such a way that we alone can
discover new objects or discover how to
use and create things already in
existence in faster more efficient and
more cost-effective ways the sources of
wealth and economic growth in market
economies depend far less upon the
possession of material things
and much more upon human insight and
human creativity creativity isn't a
morally neutral activity we can
certainly question the worth of the
prudence of any number of substances and
objects the moral worth I think of
creativity is rather demonstrated by its
opposite and its opposite is passiveness
and excessive dependency creativity of
thought of action and Association
literally transforms humanity's outlook
from one of a static or cyclical view of
life to a vision of a world open to
transformation through human endeavor
creativity permits people to break out
of set and sometimes very stagnant
patterns of life this creativity isn't
limited to just one choice or one action
on the part of one individual it
invariably involves building upon the
creative choices and insights are people
living now and people who are long dead
so the creativity that flourishes and
market economies is thus invariably
social in nature of course people can be
creative in lots of economic settings in
the conditions of 18th century
mercantilism or in contemporary
conditions of crony capitalism merchants
and business leaders can be very
creative in how they get close to
politicians to civil servants and others
who make many of the economic decisions
in those type of societies but in the
conditions of a market the incentives to
be creative in extracting resources from
the political system or to engage in
rent-seeking the incentives are just
much less by contrast in market
economies the incentives to be creative
live
in the realm of trying to ascertain what
consumers or groups of consumers might
want or need and then working to come up
with new goods and services or new ways
of providing existing goods and services
so while a market or a society might
embody great resources of creativity
market economies also help to foster a
fourth condition that's extremely
important for the common good it's a
very commonplace feature in market
economies so much so that I think we
take it for granted it passes unnoticed
in front of us and that's it's this for
all its reputation for rugged
individualism market economies are very
reliant upon in help to promote the
quality of trust now of course in the
world that existed before Adam Smith
trust wasn't unknown but as a moral
characteristic it tended to be
relatively weak outside families and it
tended to be grounded in expectations
that were attached to certain social
roles outside these boundaries deep
suspicion deep distrust of the stranger
was more often the rule the emergence of
market economies required and helped to
facilitate an extremely widespread
diffusion of a willingness to trust
other people even total strangers the
legal philosopher Roscoe Pound he didn't
exaggerate when he wrote quote wealth in
a commercial age is made up largely of
promises end quote
consider something like banking when I
deposit my surplus capital in a bank
instead of storing it under my bed it
requires an act of trust on my part in
the bank
depositors have to be willing to trust
bankers who want to make loans and
sometimes grant unsecured credits to
people that the original depositors will
never know that's pretty amazing when
you think about it so Trust is also
essential to as as important something
to the functioning of market economies
as the forming and fulfilling of
contracts when people make a contract
they're engaging of course in a
commercial convention and a Rick
recognized legal practice but these
practices presuppose a basic exercise in
promise making in which we make a choice
to commit ourselves to perform certain
actions while relying upon others to
bind themselves to doing particular
things contracts are in fact null and
void without these type of prior
commitments but if market economies
required every single agreement to
require a formal contractual endorsement
I think its ability to promote growth
would become actually quite limited so
by necessity trust in commercial
societies in market orders extends
beyond what's formally endorsed in
contract law most economic exchanges in
fact involve making promises that carry
only minimal and more often than not no
legal weight whatsoever there's a
prevailing expectation in market
economies that in most situations and
most of the time people in the
marketplace will do what they said they
were going to do now this giving and
receiving of trust assumes a certain
willingness to treat other people in
particular ways until they prove
unworthy of such trust it does involves
behaving towards other people in a
mana not necessarily in the way that
people behave with members of their
family but certainly in a manner that's
best described as civil in this sense I
think we can say that markets encourage
the growth of a fifth condition
associated with the common Gordon and
that is civility we heard a lot about
that last night but I think markets have
a very powerful role to play in
promoting civility I think it's
particularly interesting that Scottish
Enlightenment thinkers viewed this
civility as especially characteristic of
markets and commercial order they saw
commercial society is is bound together
not only by market relationships
underpinned by rational self-interest
but also by a culture of civility of
gentleness of mutual respect that paid
very little attention to a person's
background or their social status
because in market economies civility is
no longer associated with belonging to a
particular social class the civilizing
project effectively moves away from a
small group of people and embraces
increasing numbers of people as levels
of wealth grow throughout Society in
market economies many people for the
first time have the possibility of being
generous of learning to defer immediate
gratification it's precisely as Adam
Smith remarked that because quote every
person becomes in some measure a
merchant in market economies that
commerce leads increasing numbers of
people to acquire habits of order habits
of economy now part of the vision of
civility in commercial society and in
market orders involves people refraining
from using violence to achieve their
goal
it's important to remember that in the
pre commercial world pre
eighteenth-century world war was
perceived on the part of figures ranging
from Alexander the Great and Napoleon as
the path to greatness and glory by
contrast markets rely upon peace and
tend to promote peace though I think
there's a qualification that needs to be
added to that which I'll say something
about towards the end but I think the
ability of markets to promote peace is
closely associated with its undermining
of the false notion that one person's
gain is always at the expense of someone
else part of adam smith's critique of
the mercantile system of his time was
its assumption that one country's gain
could only be at the expense of others
those type of theories facilitated a
great deal of aggressive behavior of
nations towards one another as they
fought to secure colonies and exclusive
trading rights so there's considerable
incentives for market economies for
societies with market economies with
dynamic markets to avoid war the
reluctance of people living in market
orders to embark upon war isn't simply a
matter of resenting the financial
restrictions and potential losses that
are associated with the waging winning
or losing of war it also concerns
protecting the fabric of freedoms upon
which market economies are so reliant
war and I'm not a pacifist just to make
that clear I'm not a pacifist war has a
reorganizing logic of its own when
nations go to war governments are given
the authority to do things that they are
forbidden from undertaking in peacetime
and that usually involves acquiring
hours that diminish economic freedom
perhaps the greatest long-term problem
that war creates for market economies is
that the state is usually very reluctant
to relinquish its new powers once the
war is over so commercial societies
aversion to the fourth use of force
isn't confined to the sphere of Foreign
Relations it also applies to relations
within market economies as Adam Smith
explained it's not a coincidence that as
commercial towns started to develop he
said quote order and good government and
with them the liberty and security of
individuals becomes much more pronounced
people who before had lived in a
continual state of war with their
neighbors and in servile dependency upon
their superiors start to treat others
more peacefully in court at the same
time I think there's little question
that the emergence of markets creates
particular incentives for the value that
we attach to tolerance the emergence of
market economies in their expansion is
very dependent upon a degree of openness
a high degree of openness to new ideas
new cultures new endeavors a market
economy that closes itself off two
concepts or investments from people
whose political and religious beliefs
differ from the dominant culture it
places itself at an economic
disadvantage compared to those
communities that are more open to such
people indeed what's interesting about
modern commercial societies is that when
markets began to emerge in their present
form during the 18th century wealth
became much more mobile businesses
became less family orientated and much
less uniform in their linguistic
their ethnic and their religious
composition in other words the spread of
markets brought people from very
different backgrounds into contact with
one another through their mutual pursuit
of wealth the common desire to create
wealth in ways that can be permanently
sustained encourages people to soften
the intensity of their differences not
least because the persistence of those
types of obstacles over time is very
likely to encourage people to take their
business elsewhere
now a moment ago I mentioned an
important qualification to this thesis
and it's by reflection on that that I'd
like to conclude my remarks today now my
qualification is this I don't think
there's any guarantee that the growth of
markets across the globe is bound to
gradually eliminate all potential for
conflict in fact some of those who made
some of the most important contributions
to the case for the market as a way of
bolstering human wellbeing didn't think
there was a strong correlation between
peace and free markets now I especially
have in mind Scottish enlightenment
luminaries ranging from the Presbyterian
minister Francis Hutcheson to the
skeptic self-described infidel David
Hume and the man over whom they both
exercised a strong intellectual
influence who was of course Adam Smith
they didn't believe that the growth of
markets inevitably led to perpetual
peace as people like a manual cart were
trying to argue towards the end of the
18th century they didn't think that
markets would necessarily lead to what
might be called a cosmopolitan liberal
order or that the emergence of such an
order was necessarily desirable in the
first place
so why did they think this well they all
suddenly thought that free trade was a
positive sum game for all participants
and that it promoted increases in wealth
for all but they also thought that
markets and trade make nations wealthy
and that gives nations the capacity to
afford more military expenditures this
is one reason why David Hume for example
was skeptical about making too much of
this relationship between free trade and
peace he said states which become
wealthy through markets can afford and a
stay sustain Wars more easily than
poorer countries in fact Adam Smith
wrote extensively about the need to
defend one's nation against external
aggression and he emphasized the
importance of love of country and
patriotism he wasn't an advocate of
cosmopolitan internationalism smoothe
Smith it turns out was very skeptical
about proposals for cosmopolitan peace
that was starting to emerge in the
Europe of his time now Smith certainly
believed that free trade and free
markets tended to have a civilizing
effect upon people he argued that
markets channel self-interest in ways
that serve the well-being of everyone
over the long term but he didn't argue
the trade and markets would somehow
overcome all weaknesses in human nature
or even some of the strong political
disagreements between societies that are
often at the root of civil and
international conflict he even believed
that pursuit of free trade could
sometimes become an occasion for war in
as much as what he called jealousy of
trade often led to international
violence free trade Smith added not only
created more wealth that enabled and
sometimes tempted nations to go to war
markets and trade generated wealth he
said but they also encouraged nations to
stationed navies and armies at distant
places very much as Great Britain did
throughout the 19th century
as a way of promoting and protecting its
commitment to free trade throughout this
period in other words Smith didn't
believe that economic interdependence
between nations through what we would
call global markets would necessarily
and in all cases lead to a necessary
harmony of interests that interpretation
was for Smith way too deterministic
there are many other factors in play
when it comes to questions of domestic
and international peace many of which
are recorded more wait at different
times by different people so to conclude
you may be wondering why have I believe
at this point
well my basic reason is this I think
that the case for free markets and the
way that mark could serve the common
good can be undermined whenever people
make exaggerated or what you might even
call triumph allistic claims about its
contributions to the common good and
human flourishing so when you look at
the particular ways in which I've
suggested that markets serve the common
good ways that are certainly economic
but also extend into politics manners
culture and other non economic parts of
life you start to see that the
contribution of markets to the common
good
is or can be very very substantial much
more I think than most people realize
but I do think that if we want to show
the ways in which free markets serve the
common good in an age of economic
nationalism in an age of cronyism and
what often seems to me to be like an age
of neo mercantilism we need to be
clearer about what free markets can do
and what free markets can't do some of
the best and most effective advocates of
free markets have always understood this
and that in itself I'd suggest is a
substantive contribution that those of
us who favor free markets can make to
the common good today thank you very
much
[Applause]
we have about 20 minutes for questions
and answers I don't know if we have
microphones we do have microphone so
okay Sam I'm gonna let you take
I got a question and I was thinking and
wonder what's your perspective on this I
think your thesis on market economy and
common good the underpinning or maybe
the the best practice let me put it this
way the underpinning of your your market
economy and best practice is the wealth
of nation and the underpinning of the
wealth of nation is the Theory of Moral
Sentiments and the underpinning of that
is the Bible says love your neighbor as
yourself and the underpinning of that is
love God with all your heart with all
your soul with all your mind and with
all your strength in the underpinning of
that is from mark chapter 12 verse 30
and 31 which is basically the Word of
God I think that is a best practice
what's your perspective on that well I
work at the Acton Institute so I have a
lot of thoughts about that subject let
me say a couple of things do people know
where the phrase the wealth of nations
comes from I'm sure there are people
here you must know there must be people
here who know Isaiah comes from the book
of Isaiah it's mentioned four times I
think in the Book of Isaiah that wealth
of nations etc I don't think that's a
coincidence I don't think that's a
coincidence so I think that in some
senses there is definitely a type of
biblical background at work for example
even in in the work of Adam Smith who is
not a Christian Smith is not a Christian
he's a days I think that's pretty clear
but if you read his Theory of Moral
Sentiments he invokes precisely this
theme of love of neighbor he invokes
Christianity's Great Commandment and he
doesn't have to because it's a work of
philosophy it's not a work of theology
but even Smith who's not hostile to
Christianity I think is
way too friendly with david hume for my
taste
smith can't get away from
I think this deeper religious context
which he's assuming in many respects
most of his audiences accept and buy
into and at some level believing it's
very important in this context to keep
in mind that the Scottish enlightenment
once you take people like Hugh mout of
the picture Scottish enlightenment was
not an anti-christian endeavor most of
the people involved in the Scottish
enlightened were Church of Scotland
ministers they knew Adam Smith they were
friends with him so in other words there
is this this this culture this context
in which Smith is writing his Wealth of
Nations and his Theory of Moral
Sentiments and it takes many of the
assumptions that's called them biblical
assumptions for granted even if Smith
can't bring himself to believe in the
person of Jesus Christ himself he
revised his theory of moral sentiment
six times in his life and he always said
that it was his favorite ball much more
so than the wealth of nations which he
revised less but in the last revision of
the wealth other Theory of Moral
Sentiments he added a whole part six
which is all about the virtues he talks
about the prudent man the virtual
prudence but in the end he also talks
about benevolence and it's he explicitly
invokes Christian themes when he's doing
that and I think one of the reasons he's
doing this why he revises the book in
this way is because he's becoming very
conscious that by the 1790s it's
becoming more apparent that if this type
of economic system that he's thought of
and imagined and started to theorize
about is going to work then it needs all
these moral supports and to his mind
that includes sort of Greek thought
Roman Ford stoic thought but I'm
questionably involves some sort of
commitment to Christian thought thank
you
a presentation thinking about the
tension of markets fostering the common
good I'm reminded how many ways of
Christian theologians leading up to
Smith wrestle with the difficulty of
transform the development of a
commercial society in this standpoint
that previous societies have been based
much more on personal relationships
reciprocity your face-to-face dealing
with someone else and now as the market
arises it's much more a matter of
impersonal exchange and some of such as
Brian Griffiths have noticed that
Smith's deism deism kind of matches that
and invoking an impersonal God who's not
active in the world and they're in
thereby also describing an impersonal
market could you address that sort of
tension sure yes that's always been a
tension between the rise of commercial
society the rise of market orders and
the prevailing religious context of
Europe and America for that matter at
the time Christian theologians whether
they were whether they were Protestant
or Roman Catholic were very aware of
these types of tensions because in pre
commercial orders we have to keep in
mind that one level social relationships
are fixed you're a peasant or your
boudoir or your noble and you don't
change that's the way you are for your
whole life the number of people who are
Buju are is a very small group of people
a trade with one another they tend to
know who the other people are and of
course on a more basic level we're
talking about societies in which most
people didn't move more than five miles
away from the place that they were born
mobility was much more limited which
which points much more in the direction
of these
close interpersonal relationships as
opposed to these more abstract
relationships and of course the church
was integral to every part of life in
these societies from literally from
birth to death so that's that's one
thing to think about there's definitely
a tension there and it seems to me in
many cases that remains an unresolved
tension between those who hold two
Christian faith and the world of
free-market economics is there's
unquestionably attention there we see it
expressed in lots of different ways but
now that said there's also a rich
history of Christian theologians
thinking very seriously
prior to Adam Smith about many of the
important features of market economies
that we take for granted today the ideas
of contract just didn't pop out of
nowhere they had been written about by
Protestant and Roman Catholic
theologians for a very long period of
time in fact if you read Joseph
Schumpeter's history of economic
analysis he makes the point that if you
look at more or less from Aquinas up
until the early modern period he
basically says that you have theologians
of what he often called moralists people
who were specializing in moral theology
writings very seriously about the
obligations attached to contract the
whole discovery and elucidation and
exploration of the question of usury led
to all sorts the development of all
sorts of insights into the nature of
money the character of interest even a
certain understanding of the difference
between economic growth and stagnation
so all these things are there but no one
has put them all together in a
particular way really until the wealth
of nations appears that so many people
have said there's nothing new in the
wealth of nations in terms of some of
its specific analyses of anything
ranging from
some of the problems of mercantilism -
the nature of contracts but what Smith
does is put it together as a theory as
in terms of a social science and that's
where I think some of the abstractness
comes from which to my mind is an
argument for those of us who work in
Christian the Christian intellectual
tradition to work more thoroughly upon
trying to work out how these two areas
of knowledge these ways of understanding
the world can be put together because as
we often say the act at the Acton
Institute economics doesn't constitute
the whole truth about the human person
but economics as the social science
certainly does capture certain truths
about human beings and human societies
that we ignore at our peril so yes I
think the tension is an opportunity for
more extensive work to be done in terms
of working out how these things fit
together because I think the temptation
for many people of faith is to see
something like economics as well as just
applied materialism it's just applied
utilitarianism and I think that's that's
a mistake for their characteristic
they're characterizing in the first
place as a mistake but I think it's it's
also plays into a tension between
Christianity on the one hand and
modernity on the other and as I often
say to some of my brethren who would
like to go back to the Middle Ages
there's no going back to a pre
enlightenment world that doesn't mean
that everything post enlightenment is
wonderful it's not but to think that we
haven't gone through some fundamental
transformation in the way that we think
about particular questions pretend that
never happened I think is not good for
people of faith but it also means that
economists and economics as a social
science can become somewhat blind to
some truths about the human person that
we find revealed in the judeo-christian
tradition
thank you I'd like to ask you to further
comment on your reference to China and
economic and religious freedom should
one be pursued before the other is there
a causal relationship perhaps well
that's something that we'd act and have
thought a lot about in fact um my
colleague my boss Chris it probably
hasn't told you this he speaks Mandarin
I'm not joking and he goes to China
quite fragrant frequently and he can
probably tell you some very interesting
things about what's happening in terms
of the relationship between economic
development and the and its relationship
to religious liberty but let me just say
a couple of things first of all I don't
think it's a coincidence that in those
parts of China the the the special
economic zones as they're called in
eastern China which have sort of opened
up to the global economy I think as I
mentioned in my remarks we are starting
to understand now that that opening has
been much more sporadic much more
selective much less full-throttle than I
think we often assumed in the past I
think we're seeing now that I think was
the the Ambassador who said last night
it's a sort of mecan't lost arrangement
and I think that's more or less an
accurate description but in these
special economic zones where more
economic freedoms shall we say has been
allowed albeit the companies that you're
typically dealing with usually have some
involvement with either the Communist
Party the government or the Chinese
military so it's the freedom is limited
just even in that level but in these
special economic zones it's precisely
where this opening has happened this
limited but nonetheless real economic
opening has happened that you've had a
growth in religiosity why is it the case
well one of the reasons I speculate
about and I haven't done any empirical
research on this but my speculation is
that once people get out of poverty and
they're able they have some time
and leisure to think about things beyond
just mere survival they can't help but
ask themselves or what's the meaning of
all this what's the ultimate purpose of
what I'm doing where do I fit into the
ultimate scheme of history my country
etc and many people in China have found
answers to those questions in faith I
don't think it's mistake that you see
this this incredible growth mainly in
evangelical Christianity in all house
churches as they're called in
significant parts of these regions of
China I think there's a certain
correlation that's going on there so
that's a good thing that's a good thing
what's worrying of course as we all know
as was mentioned last night the Chinese
government is is has reinforced and is
cracking down because it's reinforced
this position that it has that it will
not tolerate foreign influences and what
does that mean well it means that if
Christianity is going to exist in China
it has to be on Christian I'm sorry on
what they call Chinese terms so what
does this mean well at the moment it
means things like the government is
making it very difficult for say
Christians to take their children to
church there in some places forbidding
Christian parents from trying to forbid
them from educating their children in
the Christian faith they're requiring
churches to put up pictures of the
president the Chinese president in the
church knocking down if in the case of
Catholic Church is knocking down statues
and putting up Communist Party slogans
etc etc so I think what this tells us is
that yes there is a certain relationship
between economic openness and the
potential for the growth of religious
faith I'm not sure it means a particular
faith but I think it means that people
are starting to ask questions that
religion robot tries to provide
different religions provide different
answers for but we're also seeing that
authoritarian governments that have the
will and the ruthlessness to do so who
as we're seeing in China as we're seeing
in countries like Venezuela can do that
for a very long period of time as long
as they have the will and the
ruthlessness to do so so at the moment I
think it's a very mixed bag now none of
that by the way is an argument for
moving away from even limited economic
liberalisation as I mentioned in my
remarks even the limited liberalisation
of certain parts of China that's
happened in over the past 40 years has
increased freedom to a certain degree
in parts of these countries but we're
seeing also the government's can act
against that pretty in a pretty
systematic way if they had the will and
the ruthlessness to do so so on the one
hand it's a very there is a certain
trajectory that shows this this is
happening on the other hand
authoritarian regimes tend to act in
authoritarian ways and religious liberty
is one of those things that totalitarian
regimes really can't tolerate because
one you once you accept religious
liberty it means that there's a sphere
of human life that the state has nothing
to say about an authoritarian regimes
let alone totalitarian regimes are
usually not particularly interested in
affirming that freedom we have time for
one more question
thank you I have enjoyed your
presentation but I just got a question
in my mind when you were answering one
of the question that were was posed to
you about Adam Smith not being Christian
if that were so I have about 50 years of
apologies to make to my students who
took history of economic thinking from
me the evidence revealed that he went to
Oxford primarily to become a Catholic
priest but because of moral difficulties
for professors students and others I
decided to study moral philosophy if you
can make comment on that sure I think I
will go home happy well a couple of
things first of all when he went to
Oxford he went on a scholarship that was
for people in people who were on track
to become ordained ministers in the
Church of Scotland and when he was at
Oxford he didn't actually like Oxford
very much why didn't he like Oxford well
because he thought that it was far at
the time far less intellectually serious
than the University of Glasgow or the
University of Edinburgh he also he also
looked around and noticed that a lot of
the professor's didn't work very hard
because it was because to be a professor
at these places at the time meant you
had to enter into what was called Holy
Orders so he didn't like what you would
I suppose what we would call tenure
today he thought it made people lazy
I'll let you all think about that but at
the same time he also started reading
people like David Hume and that's this
is where I think some of his doubts
about the claims of Christianity took
root he was very careful when he went
back to Scotland to teach she was very
carefully never made disparaging remarks
about Christianity in fact in his Wealth
of Nations he makes the point that
the ministers of the Church of Scotland
that he knew were among the best most
educated and most erudite people that
one could possibly meet and as I
mentioned before he couldn't get away
from the fact that the this world in
which markets were starting to emerge in
which his ideas played such a role in
encouraging what we would call
policymakers today to make radical
changes away from the mercantilist
arrangements of his time he couldn't get
away from the fact that this was these
were societies profoundly influenced by
Christianity which the overwhelming
majority of people were believing
Christians and in which Christianity had
led this left this very powerful moral
imprint and he wasn't averse to using
that moral imprint to try and explain
why he believes certain things were
should be certain ways and why certain
things should not be another way so yes
he's a deist is he hostile to
Christianity I don't think so and I
think I think in many respects he
acknowledges the importance that it had
played in shaping the type of university
life and culture that he thought was
indispensable if you are going to have
flourishing market economies and we are
done
thank you
[Applause]